alors jean michel ouais tu as besoin
d'un véritable avis aujourd'hui exact tu
m'as parlé de ton projet et tu vas voir
la vie des chroniqueurs et j'ai même
fait appeler un spécialiste pour savoir
si tu faisais le bon choix ou pas tu
nous dire à ton choix soit une affaire
après l'avis du public
elle a dit bien sûr de notre invités et
les chroniqueurs est ce que les
chroniqueurs vous savez de quoi vous
parlez jean michel vous n'êtes pas dire
c'est le principe de la séquence ils ne
savent pas de quoi va parler jean-michel
mais alors jean-michel vous allez parler
que le coeur parce que je crois que mine
de rien vous êtes un beau gosse mais
simone ceci si vous êtes beau mais il ya
un truc qui vous chiffonne une complexe
qui vaut complexe énormément et non mais
bon on me le dit à chaque fois même
quand à la caméra on dit fais attention
cyril ne montrera s'ils demandent pas ça
dans mon passé exactement
avec l'âge comme beaucoup d'hommes
malheureusement j'ai pris de
l'embonpoint et j'ai pris ils sont le
pneu voilà donc voilà malheureusement
j'habite pas à clermont-ferrand mais
j'ai le pneu voilà radial au dollar
entre est ce que le mot crise est ce que
voulait le montrent ces camps voire un
avis ça va c'est pas notre but
merci pour avoir un avis il faut alors
c'est rien bah c'est fait mouche en
s'adaptant des bâtonniers déjà déjà moi
je fais pas ça non mais voilà jean
michel ça qui nous plaît on reste ça
repart souper jean-michel donc voilà
j'ai tout tenté j'ai fait bien ce régime
du suspense je fais mal les régimes
évidemment je ne fais pas beaucoup de
stars mais la même salle de sport que ma
mère mais j'ai 75 ans le temps mais même
en faisant du sport et donc j'étais
moins bien fait pour m'en débarrasser
comme dans la grande machine parce que
du coup sa partie en 1h au lieu de 3 et
de 5 ans
on va voir on va voir si vous prenez à
bon escient que je sais que benjamin
castaldi a fait une dépression alors
jean-michel donc une liposuccion ge
nous avons eu ce que je dis c'est le
seul moyen parce que là je fonctionne
bien aussi les seins voilà un peu oui
avec ces bleus à partir de la grèce mais
heureusement mais c'est la mauvaise
graisse qui part pas même en faisant
attention savoir plus donc et s'avoue
complaisamment ouais voilà je ne vais
pas en maillot
je veux pas je mets mon maillot g46
shirts ah ouais c'est embrassera total
tout le temps et bah pas tout le temps
mais c'est un complexe vraiment alors
jean michel cohen est avec nous il va
notre nutritionniste il va nous dire
aussi si si c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
liposuccion jean-michel voilà qu'est ce
que vous en pensez il faut que deux
possibilités la première possibilité
c'est la plus simple c'est que tu te
mets au régime tu sais chez eux
tu fais des ados de la circulation et
peut-être que tu seras vraiment
satisfait la deuxième possibilité c'est
que tu peux faire une liposuccion mais
si t'as pas fait d'activité physique ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'une fois qu'on
aura enlevé la grèce qui est dessous la
peau l'apoel va-t-elle détendu donc ça
veut dire que vous devez savoir une peau
flasque alors peut-être que ça te fera
plaisir à toi mais ça changera pas le
problème du maillot de bain alors on a
on a des images de ben un américain qui
était très complexée par son montre
regardez c'est ben c'est le frère de et
notes et il a fait appel à un chirurgien
très célèbre à hollywood et vous allez
voir le résultat l'avant après je pense
c'est assez oufa oui vous allez voir je
pense que ça va vous faire kiffer
regarder ce n'était pas juste une
opération esthétique
je voulais me sentir mieux dans ma vie
et dans mon corps ont été incroyables
j'avais un tour de taille de 106 cm et
je pesait 125 kg et maintenant je fais
100 kilos et j'ai un tour de taille de
86 cm c'est du bidon
non non c'est possible mais il ya eu une
chirurgie derrière ça on voit bien que
il a creusé sur les abdominaux les
autres et en angulation et puis on voit
bien dessous la cicatrice donc il a été
obligé de refaire la peau ah ouais ça et
donc parce que la peau des adeptes que
la liposuccion c'est très simple parce
que moi j'ai fait vis ma vie de
chirurgie esthétique
je me rappelle est en fait ils vous
ouvrent ici un peu comme ça et vous
passez un tuyau et ils enlèvent toute
l'agressivité moi je ne pourrais pas et
la grèce qui tourne dans un bocal on
faire un castaldi vous êtes pour ou pas
moi bien sûr
oui moi je pense que ça ça coûte une
liposuccion née autour de laver blanc
déchirure au 1510 les gens me veut faire
il faut faire plusieurs zones qui veut
faire les il va faire les paie qui va
faire le dos il fallait parler d'amour
c'est faire lever ce père qui vont pas
descendre trop bas voilà mais non moi je
moi je trouve que c'est une pointe de
l'ailé pose ce beau j'en ai fini avec
les années c'est que si on appuie sur
n'a pas fait un petit régime avant la
grèce elle est très dure et que ça peut
y ait des risques ont une peau qui est
dégueulasse avec des neuf rappelle la
tôle ondulée et c'est pas beau donc c
il est beau il c'est une très bonne idée
mais tu dois faire un effort au moins
d'un mois il a déjà habillé serait plus
vite quand tu seras plus vite mais ce
serait vraiment pas beau ça met à poil
tu seras pas alors il faut savoir est ce
que vous lui coûter oui entouré la vie
de certains d'entre eux oui moi non je
préfère qu'il fasse du sport parce que
ça sert à rien de faire ni parmi son
bail peut pas il en france attend mais
y'a des trucs super 98 avec l'arrêté
avec ça je connais vous à mi régime fera
jamais voilà le 10 janvier je fais
passer un bac es dit la vérité
moi je suis d'accord avec elle c'est de
la détermination ça veut dire que si tu
en as sikkah de s'auto j'ai pas mieux
maintenant si tu veux tu viens avec moi
au sport tu vas tout perdre on ne
viendra jamais c'est terminé americana
qui commence
j'emmerde pas il le fera jamais moi je
comprends sa souffrance il en parle je
devrais t'en parle depuis plusieurs
années maintenant je sens que ça te
complexe c'est un truc vraiment intime
et personnelle faut pas que ce soit une
béquille à court terme moi j'ai peur que
ce soit si tu fais pas de sport si tu
mets la main gorée après ça reviendra
comme avant peut-on meilleur ami il est
il est foutu comme mister univers est ce
que tu pourrais pas te conseiller camion
dans la salle qui essaient de lanvaux
bah oui ce son meilleur ami oui c'est
vrai que pauvres souffrent beaucoup de
la delà de la comparaison je peux je
peux alors vous pas parce que c'est vrai
mais jeter dans la vérité si c'est pour
faire juste une liposuccion j'ai un très
bon et mieux que tu connais qu'il l'a
fait effectivement c'est 5000 euros
foutu en l'air
lecture bouffe un tout petit peu ses
revenus ça ne sert à rien soit tu fais
la totale c'est à dire tu fais la
liposuccion dr tu fais effectivement
coupe un peu la peau tu m'aimes
éventuellement un peu de faux peck et
tout pardon mais tu te lâches vraiment
qu'un de gaza les non-jeûneurs avec faut
que devait encore hommage à main non je
crois qu'ils ont fait rien mais la
liposuccion à cinq mille balles et
chacals jean-michel j'ai vraiment un ami
qui l'a fait tout à côté de moi
un mois après il avait tout repeint hors
norme et si je perds je serai motivé
après pour conserver
michel aulas oui oui vous dites il n'a
aucune assise nuitées ils s'aiment pas
moi j'arrive pas mais ça ça parait pour
la liposuccion
il frappe à tous les trucs qu'il faut
faire pour se maintenir il apprécie ce
faire liposucer il adore mais non c'est
non mais la version séparée sport mais
je fais du gainage mais en général on a
envie d'en faire mais non mérités avec
moi je parle en connaissance de cause je
connais très bien mon jour mis un jour
me il ne fera jamais de l'art et essai
liposuccion pas l'évolution c'est vous
accomplissez parce qu'une femme nous a
fait un reproche non je me le fais
moi-même du coq ces personnages que vous
regardez mieux parfois dans la nasse
je me prends parfois en photo nue dans
la glace pour essayer mais motivé
essayer de ne pas nous faire opérer et
là vous dites j'ai pas mal de brioches
pas mal non plus je dis pas que je
montre et le vent mais j'ai pas mangé
depuis deux jours pour être moins gros
non c'est vrai à votre avis non va pas
bien c'est hadj a vu black ait mis si on
cherche avec rires et en afrique les
gens cherchent à grossir oui ouais
intérêts sam et tu dois te lire atteint
d'autres mondes nous cherchons à maigrir
alors qu'en afrique les gens cherchent à
grossir m'estime très beau comme ça tu
es avec moi ni mes droits compris les
yeux il ya juste un truc que tu fais une
liposuccion en réalité ça va créer un
facteur de motivation paris-nice est ce
à dire que le fait de devoir différents
et pilot chirurgie va te dire si vous
faites rien derrière ça vous avez fait
ça pour rien peut-être que ça va te tuer
et tu seras comme tu as envie d'elle je
pense pas c'est quand même sur les
choses voilà bah alors où jean mi on va
voir ce qu'on peut les téléspectateurs
qu'est ce que disent et respectez vous
leur offrez série s qui sont pour bâle
et non 71%
les téléspectateurs sont contre et
jean-michel c'est votre décision est ce
que vous allez le faire ou pas je vais
aller faire un devis déjà sylvia
m'annonce que ses 15000 bas mais je vous
dis ça va être énormément d'argent
après ce que vous avez économisé bien
faire 60 je vais commencer à vivre que
de deux et maintenant ce sera pas moins
timide donc c'est énormément d'argent
ans à venir non mais ça veut dire que
c'est pour ça que vous admirez c'est une
grosse décision et ses grosses décisions
mais si je me sens bien dans ma peau
après n'ont donc
le faire donc vous allez c'est pas de
grosses dépenses moi je ne dépense pas
j'ai pas de yacht j'ai pas de donc non
mais n'en reste du monde à des hauteurs
tout le monde a déclaré que vous donc
vous allez faire donc venez de faire oui
j'ai économisé je me suis voilà donc
c'est bien c'est même le voir donner à
notre avis qui n'a pas du tout
[Applaudissements]